EU finance ministers will discuss the
Commission's multi-billion euro
investment plan when they meet in
Brussels on the 27th of January
specifically they will discuss a recent
proposal by the Commission to establish
a European fund for strategic
investments the fund will finance large
numbers of projects to create jobs
enhance growth across the EU ministers
will learn more from the Commission on
how this new financial instrument will
remove barriers to investment and
leverage some 315 billion euros of
largely new money in the European Union
the new fund will be placed in the hands
of the European Investment Bank
ministers have welcomed the creation of
an advisory hub designed to assist
potential investors in making the most
out of the fund some Member States
question the new fund claiming it is
underfunded so ministers will try to
push for clarification the 28 ministers
are also expected to adopt a new measure
preventing corporate tax avoidance their
goal is to deter businesses from playing
with the blocks divergent tax laws